el voto latino no sólo es importante en
estas elecciones en florida sino va a
ser más y más importante en las futuras
elecciones eso es porque el conjunto de
personas que llamamos latinos son la
minoría más grande en eeuu la minoría
étnica más grande en eeuu y se espera
que ésta siga creciendo ahora por años
se ha hablado que las republicanos se le
acaba el tiempo porque veíamos una
tendencia en la que los republicanos
buscaban mayor y mayor apoyo de las
personas blancas exprimían ese voto
blanco tratando de impulsarlo a las
elecciones y se esperaba que ésta fuera
tal vez la última elección en la que
pudieran con esa estrategia mientras que
por ejemplo se esperaba que perdieran
voto entre mujeres entre personas
afroamericanas y bueno estaba la duda
sobre el voto latino
ahora resulta que claro este voto latino
no es un monolito para latinos hay
muchos y cada uno tendrá su propia en su
propia convicción exacto y si los temas
que le importan pero vemos que los
latinos en eeuu si tienen mucha afinidad
con el partido republicano
y son en algunos asuntos wang wang
border y sus one water agua ni souliers
son esos esos electores que votan por un
asunto por ejemplo el del aborto
entonces eso puede ser una nueva
estrategia para el partido republicano
tratar de captar ese voto latino lo más
posible tal vez cambiar su discurso
frente al tema de la migración y así
entonces después tener una estrategia a
largo plazo porque si no los demócratas
seguro tendrán muy buenos años en las
siguientes elecciones